الهجوم من الواضح من خلال الصور انها نفذت
ربما في ساعه متاخره من الليل وربما فجرا
هل تم توضيح هذه المساله
نعم تم توضيعنا هجوم حدث بعد منتصف الليل
يبدو في ساعه متاخره دون تحديد
موعد بالضبط ولكن من الواضح انه نعم في
ساعات مبكره لنقل خاصه وان الفجر هنا في
موسكو يبدا الان تقريبا بحدود الساعه
الثالثه صباحا يعني يبدا يظهر الضوء مع
بدايه الساعه الثالثه صباحا كونها منطقه
شماليه ينعكس فيها التوقيت الصيفي ويصبح
النهار اطول كل ما اقترب الصيف وبالتالي
نتحدث عن بعض منتصف الليل وربما قبل
الساعه الثالثه صباحا من ناحيه ثانيه
لحد الان غير
تفضل تفضل تفضل
من ناحيه ثانيه من غير
الوقت من اي جهه جاءت هذه الدرونات هذه
المسيرات هل هي تم ضربها من خارج الحدود
الروسيه وهذا امر واستبعد ان تصل كل هذه
المسافات سيما او انه واضح من حجم
الانفجارنا وانفجار محدود اغلب على الاقل
هذا ما ترشحه الان الوسائط الاعلاميه او
الوسائل الاعلام التي تدرس هذا الحادث
بانها ربما اطلقت من داخل العاصمه من
الروسيه موسكو من مسافه قريبه ربما يصعب
على الرادارات
الاوسع ان تقصدها سيما وانه منذ اشهر
تقريبا تم نشر مضادات صواريخ مضادات طيران
مختلف انواع الدفاعات الجويه هنا ابتداء
من اس 400 المتطوره انتهاء منصات بانسر
التي تستهدف درجه الاولى صواريخ الصغيره
الحجم والمسيرات عثمان
يعني اذا كان هذا حدث بالليل
ونشاهد الدخان في هذه الصور الشحيحه التي
وصلت هل يعني هذا
ان الامر كان قد رصد يعني كان هناك حديث
ان شيئا ما غامض حدث في الكرملين لم يعلن
عنه الا بعد ساعات
في الحقيقه روسيا دوله الدوله فيها نظام
امني قوي هذه الامور لا يعلن عنها في وقت
سابق الا من كان ربما في محيط تلك المنطقه
وفي محيط تلك المنطقه توجد فنادق كثيره
فنادق من الخمس النجوم مناطق سياحيه تستمر
فيها الحياه حتى ساعات متاخره من الصباح
حتى في مختلف فصول السنه وبالتالي ربما ان
الحادث محدود من حيث ربما الضجه
او تاثيره الفعلي على المكان هو ربما له
تاثير معنوي هذا بدون شك له تاثير معنا
برايي الكثيرين كونه استهدف قلب العاصمه
روسيا مركز صنع القرار في موسكو وبدون شك
على الاقل من معرفتنا بمزاج او عقليه
تفكير اساسا روس سيكون الرد معاكسا